I'm joined Now by John McFall John is
the world's first parastronaut uh now
tell me just what does that mean
so Issa have proposed a para astronaut
feasibility project and what that
involves is trying to work out what are
the limitations and what are the things
prohibiting uh someone with a physical
disability from going into space
identifying those
solving those problems and then actually
seeing once we've solved those problems
can we feasibly send someone with a
physical disability to work in space and
your physical disability as well I'm a
through knee amputee
so uh this is your right there was a
motorcycle accident wasn't it it was
yeah uh about 22 years ago I had a
motorcycle accident and and lost my
right leg through the knee uh and uh
then went on to get involved in
paralympic sports uh and then trained as
a doctor and now I'm here today on
behalf of visa for this para astronaut
feasibility project are you being very
modest there you're actually one of
bronze medal in Beijing at the
Paralympics uh I did yes yeah maybe I
downplayed it a little bit yeah it was a
tremendous opportunity and Beijing was a
formidable games what a wonderful
stadium and to compete in and a great
opportunity so I'm very proud to have
had that opportunity but it's quite a
journey isn't it from paralympian to
para uh astronaut what do you think
this is going to lead you to
well I think in the first instance this
is about understanding the the
limitations of
um getting someone with a physical
disability into space ultimately I hope
that translates for me into an
opportunity for space flight but do you
think that a disability a physical
disability of the of your legs is is an
impediment to to space flight at all
well I think that's really the the very
point of the project uh you know and we
know that and Tim Peak has often said
that everybody is disabled in space in
in microgravity and actually we don't
know if
being an amputee either wearing a
prosthesis or not wearing a prosthesis
is an advantage is it a disadvantage we
don't know which is the whole reason
behind this project but it would be
really exciting to to see you getting a
stint on the ISS but you're not there as
a space tourist you will be there as a
professional astronaut oh absolutely you
know my my intention is to is to be
there and work and contribute to the
tremendous science that that goes on on
places like the International Space
Station but it is just a matter of
working out what you need to to do that
job to your best ability exactly yeah
and that might be the Journey 2 space
that is the the trickiest part or is
there something else that you would
envisage that needs to be overcome to
make it work I think it's
multi-factorial I think you could
probably break it down into how do you
train how does my amputation and my
disability affect the the preparation
that you need to do on Earth how does it
affect your
um you being fitted into a spacecraft
into a spacesuit for being sent to
wherever you're going and then actually
how does it affect you physiologically
and
um functionally in microgravity so those
are probably the three domains that we
would have to consider John thank you
very much indeed